ترغب موسكو انقره في المضي قدما نحو انشاء
مركز اقليمي لتصدير الغاز في تركيا فكان
ذلك من ابرز ما تحدث بشانه رئيسها البلدين
في مكالمتهم الهاتفيه
يستهدف الطموح التركي واستغلال الموقع
الاستراتيجي للبلد بين اوروبا واسيا
الوسطى والشرق الاوسط لتحويل تركيا الى
حلقه وصل بين مصدري الغازي ومستهلكيه الان
وقد توقفت امدادات الغاز الروسي لاوروبا
عبر انابيب نيرد ستريم واحد واثنين ما
زالت كميه اقل تصل عبر الانابيب العابره
الى القاره الاوروبيه من اوكرانيا
وبلغاريا تقدر باقل من 10% من ما تستهلكه
دول القاره
مكالمه اردوغان بوتين سبقها لقاء جمع
الرئيس التركي بالرئيس التنفيذي لشركه غاز
بروما الروسيه اكد اردوغان خلاله ان
البلدين سيعملان فورا على تنفيذ مقترح
بوتين لنقل الغاز الروسي عبر تركيا الى
القاره الاوروبيه
بعين الريبه ينظر مفوض السياسه الخارجيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل الى هذا
التقرب التركي الروسي فقد قال ان عدم
استعداد تركيا للانضمام الى العقوبات
الغربيه على روسيا مدعاه للقلق لا تخفى
معالم ازمه الغاز التي ما فتئت تهدد شتاء
الاوروبيين رغم استمرار مساؤهم للتضييق
على الصادرات الروسيه على خلفيه حرب
اوكرانيا حتى في ظل حاجتهم الماسه للغاز
الروسيه
الطاقه لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي في اجتماعهم
المقرر الثلاثاء المقبل حيث سيناقشون سقفا
لسعر الغازي الروسي واستنقسام بين الدول
الاعضاء تقول الدول المؤيده لسقف اسعار
الغاز ان هذا الاجراء سيحمي اقتصاداتها من
ارتفاع تكاليف الطاقه لكن دول مهمه مثل
المانيا وهولندا تعارض ذلك
ليس الوقت المتاح امام الاوروبيين طويله
فها هي ايام الشتاء حلت او تكاد لكن
خيارات تعويض الغاز الروسي ما زالت غير
كافيه قال الكريم لن تعليقا على ذلك ان
الدول الاوروبيه الراغبه في التخلي عن
اعتمادها على الغاز الروسي اصبحت تعتمد
على الغاز الامريكي المسال واضاف انهم
سيخسرون بذلك مليارات اليورو يوميا وهو ما
ستستفيد منه واشنطن فتكلفه الغاز المسال
قد ترهق ميزانيه هذه الدول اذا استغنت به
عن كميات مهمه من الغاز الروسي القادم عبر
الانابيب بتكلفه منخفضه